[Music]
hi are you the actor Andy Samberg I am
I'm a big fan man oh thank you very much
hey I got a question for
you you want to get
in Thomas Walcott single no children no
dependence job is Network management
physically
fit guess they're not too strict about
that one I'm joking kind of serious
though
you have been selected to partake in the
biggest reality show in the dark
web there will be people trying to kill
you the hunters what are you talking
about there people trying to murder
me oh very much so you will have 30
days to survive you will only be killed
when you are alone so let me get this
straight you cannot touch me if I'm with
someone and then I get a million dollars
what are you doing what are you doing
man why' you leave my side I didn't take
a why didn't you wake me up and
bring me with you because I'm taking a
let's
play what the is this this is James
my new friend you B me to Shadow him you
cannot have this person sleeping in
Mom's house are you going to Shadow me
no are you going to Shadow me no
are you going to Shadow me I don't want
to take away James's
job this is going to end badly aren't
there other people playing the game who
could hang out with you just say it
you're not gonna no I'm not g to murder
you are you g to murder me no I want to
be on the same team as you you want to
spend all our time together after
knowing me for 5 minutes let's
win together one way or
[Music]
another they can't kill us we're
together right okay good night I hope no
one murders either of
you wake up you are not as safe as you
think you are
[Music]
hi
[Applause]
guys are you playing the game I guess I
did it cuz I want to be around people
more I think we did it for
the I don't want to burst your bubble
but the game is a comedy how is it a
comedy they're trying to kill
[Music]
us I see it all
get in the
[Applause]
car you been having fun did you just ask
about having fun um yes
no